it came true
there are so many people whose
generosity and support is the reason
that I'm standing here right now I must
thank Hugh Jackman
Hugh you're the best
the cast The Crew especially
Simon Hayes and the sound Wizards
congratulations on tonight you guys the
creative team behind Les Miserables
I want to thank my friends especially
the ones who are cheering from Crosby
Street tonight my family who I'm so
blessed to be a part of my husband
by Far and Away the greatest moment of
my life was the one when you walked into
it I love you so much
and
thank you for this here's hoping that
someday in the not
too distant future the misfortunes of
fontine will only be found in stories
and Nevermore in real life thank you